they rolled up JPL
they're doing this this segment is
brought to you by ascended health
ascended health comm that's right right
there so what are we doing this morning
Jason
well role dog is gonna head to the pool
for what our and our swim tapirs
officially started so normally Sunday's
would be a big run day for me I can't I
can't even remember the last time I
didn't have like a huge run on a Sunday
so it's almost like a holiday for me but
not for Jason what are you going today
16 miles on the Queen Kay but we're all
good it's beautiful we're blessed very
vibrant day outside mm-hmm we had an
awesome morning thank you guys all for
all your email responses and we're
trying to fire them back to you guys so
give us a little time we're gonna start
tapering this week so I'll have a lot
more time to get back to you if you
haven't checked out the video that both
Jason and I posted of Jason on the bike
yesterday he's standing up in his seat
you got to go check that out
it's super inspirational and it's pretty
miraculous man I mean you know I don't
know if it's a coincidence but the first
day that Jason had tried out the
Compton's products from Ascended health
it's the same day that he was able to
stand up in a Cell for the first time so
coincidence maybe but maybe not
there's something going on here and I
was just blessed and privileged to be
able to witness that it was a really
cool thing and we're just we're pretty
excited about it and we're just trying
to keep the good energy flowing so this
morning we wanted to show you a little
bit about what we do with the Vitamix
with the vegetables we did that Vitamix
the other day that was fruit one right
all right so today we thought we'd do a
veggie one so hey roll what do we got
here we got a bunch of stuff looks like
UN it looks like you went to the farmers
market it looks like maybe we did do you
think'll beautiful everything looks so
vibrant today mm-hmm so you know a lot
of fresh organic vegetables from the
farmers market and we're gonna
we're just gonna we're gonna brew up a
blended salad basically and drink it for
breakfast before we go work out so just
a couple things I mean look you know and
everybody can kind of play with this
themselves and figure out what works for
them and what they like and we're just
we're gonna make one with the stuff that
we have here so in this one we got all
sorts of stuff as you can see we've
already kind of put it in there and cut
it up already but we got celery we got
carrots we got beets
we got peppers cucumber some ginger all
great veggies and what I usually do is
when I'm making a veggie one they tend
to be more on the kind of spicy side so
I the only kind of fruit that I would
generally mix it with that is something
like apple or maybe an orange and lemon
every time so when you when you put too
many fruits and vegetables in the same
one it kind of confuses the taste so
this one's pretty much a veggie Vitamix
I've got some lemon in there and then
the other thing that's great
when you do a veggie one is to put a
little sea salt in there and we're
blessed to have some pure Hawaiian sea
salt Michelle this stuff is from Kauai
thank you for blessing this is crazy
little we've been using it and they're
also you can get the Hawaiian red salt
you ever had that
that's all we get that at the health
food store and some of that would be
good so I usually put like a pinch of
that in there too because it kind of
like to tell you not too much but you
know a little spicy tang and we also put
some maca in there we got some coconut
oil throw a little a little squirt of
the hemp oil and flaxseed oil too and
got water in here we're out of juice
normally probably throw a little bit of
apple juice in there just give it you
know
flavor because this is this is the
hardcore one man you know this is like
downing an entire salad in a drink so
the great thing about the Vitamix too is
that if you were to eat all these
vegetables in one sitting
it would probably explode your intestine
it's just too much for your body to
handle but when you when you puree it
like this and it's blend into such a
fine you know to such a fine extent it's
highly absorbable into your body so your
body is able to absorb more of the
nutrients and fiber and everything else
in here so you're getting more nutrition
than you ordinarily would even if you
were to just eat it so one of the things
that I've noticed since being with the
roadog for the past two weeks is that he
has absolutely no problems using the
restroom and is actually a good sign
because you know as as athletes and just
as you know people trying to be healthy
in general we we need to do that we need
to continue to flush and clean our you
know clean our body and get rid of the
toxins that we have as as athletes and
role dog has no problems to go in
between four and five times a day and I
think that that is a good sign that all
of his waist and his coccyx are leaving
the body and so you know the the
healthier you eat the more organic I
know it's it's really hard to eat raw
but here you know we're showing you a
prime example that you can eat you can
eat raw you can be an endurance athlete
and to be quite honest with you the past
two weeks we've had some of the most
amazing workouts and I have not had you
know I've been a vegetarian for about
twenty years right I don't he read me
and I always thought that I needed fish
in my diet to get that protein and the
past two weeks have had absolutely no
fish and so we've gone completely
organic what about the earth and raw no
dairy whatsoever no cheese no milk
and I never really had any of that you
know in the fridge and stuff but prime
example that you can go the distance and
go long and go hard and recover well
with what we've been bringing to you and
showing you so we'll continue to bring
you guys a step inside our world and
role dogs gonna fix this up the that
we're going to call it the kind today
because it's probably a little specialty
and then we're gonna head out and get
our workout on and big props to Compton
over at ascended health had an amazing
experience yesterday as you guys are
seeing on video we you know rolled up
captured it on video and we're still
kind of in awe over what's taking place
but it's just a prime example but you
cannot stop believing so whatever you're
going through whatever you want you know
maybe you're not going through anything
maybe you want something you know
whether it's a career relationship
finances anything in life that you want
we create our own destiny so reach out
grab it continue to look at the finish
line because it's it's it's right there
let's brew this up I'll just say let's
do it you know what I forgot we're
putting the our star fruit in there to
actually at the start food was uh kind
of tasty it was kind of it was a first
for me
it's good stuff so here we go this is
what you use to press this stuff now to
make sure
give it a try let's roll
and you guys if you want to learn a
little bit more about scented health and
Compton you could Google Compton wrong
or om and look at the videos he's got
some really cool video interviews where
he talks about its take on nutrition and
wellness and it's pretty mind-blowing
stuff so mind-blowing to the point where
yesterday after my ride I ended up
spending the the next two hours watching
his videos and reading more about the
research and development that he's
working on it's just absolutely you know
pen of all makes sense what he's talking
about and it's just amazing so if you
guys want to be inspired definitely
Google Compton's ascended Health
Products and jump on board it's right
now all right let's give us a taste
cheers Cheers chiller is work out there
really good good use this as salsa you
know the good hot summer soup hey thanks
for stopping in guys it's Sunday
beautiful day here in coming up we're
blessed and thanks for all the feedback
and stay onboard we're gonna rock this
aloha plant-strong catching up with you
later